joining me now is military analyst
retired Air Vice Marshal Sean Bell and
Sean we're fast approaching this
deadline for evacuation How likely is it
that we'll get all of those who want to
get out out
it's difficult to know because from a
purely maths perspective we're going to
struggle to get 2 000 people out uh in
time but there is a question of how many
want to as you say 536 British Nationals
by the end of last night it's worth
pointing out that the flights are going
from Wally said which is about 30
kilometers north of Khartoum uh six
flights so far each of those have a
capacity of over 100 passengers so if
you do the maths we're clearly not
operating that air Link at capacity at
the moment over 2 000 British Nationals
have registered with a foreign officer
for their evacuation plan and there is a
steady flow of people arriving at the
airport some of them are not British
Nationals but we understand that they
are filling the flights if they are not
completely full with other other nations
Nationals the issue here is how many of
aboriginals actually want to fly out uh
by via the air because many of them may
have alternative ways of getting out and
how many that want to can actually not
make the journey up there and it's
really hard to know whether this supply
and demand is actually balanced at the
moment and what about trying to extend
the window we manage to get at thriving
negotiations I mean is that a
possibility well the current ceasefire
um between the Sudanese Army and the rsf
uh runs out at midnight
um and there's a picture of a cartoon
just to put it into perspective of from
the 16th of April which is before
um the ceasefire was agreed and it just
shows how dangerous and difficult it is
in the city uh outside these ceasefires
foreign secretary James cleverley has
said that until he's got certain
guarantees from the Sudanese government
but they expire at midnight and the
challenge is what happens after then
they are looking at diplomatic efforts
to try and extend the uh deadline
understand that the Sudanese Army Chief
has agreed in principle to a 72-hour
further extension but of course it
remains to be seen with the rsf and
other elements are are content with that
but actually regardless of that the
British military have also said that
they would be able to continue to
operate the AirHeads beyond the deadline
they have layer Defense Force protection
in place the real issue there is whether
or not they'd get the permissions from
the Sudanese government and the Army and
there's a political judgment to be made
about whether that stays open and you've
flown planes into these dangerous
situations before what are the the risks
I mean how do you balance up the
the risks of of going into somewhere
like this trying to get people out
safely not losing your aircraft not
losing people what are the kind of
things that you're thinking about yeah I
mean one of the judgments obviously is
the pilot but also the crew and that's
part of the challenge but let's come on
to that because I think first of all
there are other options to get people
out it's not just aircrafts we pack an
aircraft follow 120 people that's a very
juicy Target if that comes down and
diplomatically that will be a nightmare
the alternative routes are night driving
the trouble is fuel is in very short
supply at the moment there's all sorts
of blockades on the road and the like uh
and even bus tickets are costing
astronomic in terms of money to try and
get out to Egypt for example reports of
fourteen thousand dollars just to hire a
bus out Port Sudan offers an alternative
to get out there's ships HMS Lancaster's
on its way there uh that will provide
the volume that gets people out but it's
still 500 miles of driving to get out
there so as you say the Airfield it's
much quicker it's much closer and the
challenge there is that if it can be
kept open the risks though let's go come
to the risks the students governments
and the Sudanese Army is there any I
mean is there any evidence that they
would Target a an aircraft intentionally
or is the risk more that it that gets
hit accidentally in the in the crossfire
well it's a great question if we were
doing this at cartoon Airfield there
would be a risk of both there'd be a
risk of um but actually because this
airfield's 30 miles away it's away from
built up areas it will almost certainly
have to be deliberately shot down and
therefore is it the Sudanese government
or the Army they're probably not a
threat is the rsf a threat it would be
but why would it prioritize that over
trying to take the city which it seems
to be doing at the moment looters and
those people who are uh are trying to
cause problems on the criminal front
they almost certainly wouldn't attack a
a an Airfield that's been protected by
the military
um but the RAF transport Force having
been involved with that in my time in
Afghanistan they are incredibly well
experienced with operating operation
environment they are very used to
balancing the threats and one of the
measures for example that they would
take is they probably operate only at
night because the threats are likely to
be from all arms from guns and it's a
lot more difficult to see a Target at
night so one of the things they could do
is only operate the air bridge at night
but whatever happens if the government
is to extend the opening hours of that
air Bridge there's going to be a really
interesting balance of risk and reward
and that's a political decision not a
military one and and in terms of the
planes themselves and capacity my
understanding is that they normally
perhaps carry with looking at some of
these big transporter planes they might
normally carry 100 110 Army Personnel
but they can carry a lot more civilians
can't they because I guess they haven't
they haven't got great big kit bags I
mean although they'll probably have
whatever belongings they happen to carry
they can squash a lot more people in if
they want to they can and part of it's
how much baggage so if you've now been
forced to evacuate your home you're
probably not going to be carrying a
little handbag you're probably going to
be carrying a whole load of suitcases
with you and every suitcase is a weight
of a child and therefore there's a
balance to be be struck there but I'm
down to the military aircraft as you say
you can pack a lot more people in there
if you need to and you kind of overload
the aircraft as well if you need to at
the moment it doesn't appear that
capacity is the issue okay sure thanks
very much